well we had Jennifer Tilly and I thought
it could not get any sexier and then
here she is once again ladies and
gentlemen this time with Sean baker
filmmaker responsible for the florida
project for the second day in a row
it's sandy came Sean I do have a
complaint is that I tried to watch it
two days in a row and I kept having an
issue with the feed I got like 15
minutes in it's great what I saw and I
kept having issues where I couldn't saw
I wasn't gonna issue with your film it
was just with the thievery about that by
the way I have a message I'm gonna read
on the air which I normally don't it's
from Colin Quinn
he says Sean Becker made a movie called
takeout yeah amazing exclamation point
he wrote best indie film of all time and
then he writes I know saying indie films
should earn me a savage tire iron thing
he came out to do yeah he saw takeout or
prints a Broadway one of my earlier
films at the Angelika and I was like I
see I've been listening to you guys for
years like thank you all the
incarnations all the way back to W n UW
so when I saw him seeing my film I was
like just in awe and I was starstruck
etc etc so anyway it's great that's
great to be here thank you thank you for
being I don't know if you know this but
we got Sandy's contact information
through you guys did you I'm friends
with Ty West oh yeah
and so I was like I want sandy to be in
my film find her information and she
reached out to either rocker Travis or
something so you had this movie in mind
to do the Florida project which is like
and and you're just like you know sandy
from the show and you're like I want her
to be one of the remote people who live
in the motel yeah that's awesome
like 30 years ago with you know the
public access show she had well I still
have it on Eman and every Saturday night
11 p.m. we're running the trailer of
Sean's family the florida project well
honestly if it wasn't for all the
appearances she had on your show I
wouldn't know how like how funny she was
improv yes right it was really because
of you guys that I wonder my favorite
thing with sandy was when she would talk
to like these penthouse girls and
analyze what was wrong with them and
they're not used to that she hits
Lumbee man watching the movie and I said
this yesterday but like is kind of
freaking out because first I was like oh
my god it's really sandy can't see
anything she's really and the scene by
the pool she lets out it like she does
and then the scene when she's talking to
Willem Dafoe not in a hostile way at the
motel right she goes hello yeah and that
Johanna what that's the way he directs
the movie just like just be yourself
just improv and when he puts it can I
say it you know the the the shirt he
says covered up the children are
watching and he's gonna call the sheriff
I said no I'm gonna call the sheriff you
just fondled me yes and fondled it's
very sandy kiss eh sure Willem Dafoe was
telling her tits away because there's
kids watching she's in a motel pool and
she's going what tits me and what tit I
think she was actually really driving
Willem crazy like even Mary Sigler from
page say was it oh no Richard Johnson
said it was a love story between you and
Willem I said no it was a hate story he
hated you yeah he's gay he hated you I
mean why how could he not like you yeah
just be yourself and that was all at the
top of my titties what you want to do
next are getting Oscar buzz on this
movie the only thing that could be
better is if chip-chip person was in
there well okay first off I love chip I
your podcast episodes like multiple
times and like and just and and you've
kept me entertained on this press tour
I've been you know and I just listened
to the live one the other day and
freaking awesome that's all I can say
let's make a chip Jefferson we're gonna
get you on his podcast Oh
go naked yeah but he says he's healing
like the blue language but he sees a big
blue language but he's very popular
he'll do good for you okay is your
question to my tangerine to the family
and that was the thing about that was
not just the the like the the content of
it but the way that does you shot on
iPhones right which is uh how was that
done because it was so cool like it was
like little long shots yeah I mean they
were like long discussions it seemed
like it was all one take it was like it
was a desperate move at first we had
like a micro budget and the only way we
had already written the script and it
was no way we're gonna pull it off for
that budget so it would just happen to
be at the time that the 5s came out and
like there was a jump in the technology
with HD video and there were all these
other tools there was an app and like
this we were able to shoot it in true
scope and a morphic so does that mean it
means that um it's like the widescreen
cinema you would see in like good bad
and ugly like Oh stretched out and it
was like it wasn't manipulated in post
it was like an actual like we were
shooting it this way for the cinema and
it just happened to work we go to
Sundance that year we thought we were
gonna be like one of 10 iPhone movies
because the technology had reached that
point and we are the only one and
suddenly we got all this buzz about it
and it helped with the promotion of it
and thank you guys because you actually
talked a lot about it yeah did you have
the separate lens to put on it or no it
mean yeah there was a little adapter
that fits over it it's created by this
company called moon dog labs but besides
that no it does it wasn't like everyone
was saying you had a pimped-out iPhone
but it wasn't it was just if you saw us
from across the street shooting the only
giveaway that we were like a
professional crew was our boompole so
you had to follow them with that also
for the camera - uh yeah buddy just I
was just hand holding a little iPhone
and like it was and it was before the
plus size so we lost our eyesight we had
no external monitors we were just
squinting the entire time but does it
make you want to like because I was
sitting there when I was watching the
Florida project and took me a little
while before I was like okay this is not
done on iPhones no we went the other way
like it yeah yeah do you go cuz at first
it's like well I feel like if you
figured out how to make a movie on an
iPhone you just make all your movies on
iPhones
well maybe you don't want to be the
iPhone movie guy
that's exactly it plus there it we did
want this thing to be gorgeous 35
millimeter and a morphic and willem
dafoe yeah and so he had money he's a
[ __ ] star I mean I have flyers with
his name on it and I have I flipped the
bird with him and I have a picture and
actually more about you is capturing
sandy Kane on thirty five-millimeter
the man is a big [ __ ] star yes John I
mean everyone knows well you know that's
funny
unfortunately because because of the
technical problems I couldn't see it all
I was watching and there was one shot
you took that it's like when you notice
a shot it was the kids sitting in front
of this this giant mural yeah of like
oranges right and it was a great way to
show like this is this like really weird
friendly mural that like and look at the
poverty well that area route 192 which
is like the main artery that leads to
the parks in Orlando and Kissimmee
Florida it's lined with all these like
candy coated colored small businesses
because they were targeting the same
tourists so there's you have a magic a
purple magic castle Motel you have a big
orange dome you have all these things
that are just like vibrant with color
and it was easy to capture that stuff
and and also my my DP my director of
photography alexis sabe he shot like all
the D Antwoord videos and comment video
and plus like these high brow films I
went to can from Mexico so like he just
captures it in such a beautiful way yes
how long did it take you to find the
Magic Castle because that's like or did
you see that I like I have to make a
movie based on that thing because it
really is like yeah an important writer
in the movie The Wizard it's the big
purple no that was a gift shop oh it's
right next door right okay that whole
purple thing yes yeah it was just
literally like a mile a strip route 192
within that mile you have all
those wonderful things and you had that
magic castle Motel that we just saw and
we were already writing the script but
we said Mooney the little girl has to
live in her own castle so it was that
use did you know the look like was it
like this like oh this location is so
fascinating to me I want to write a
story around this location or okay so
basically my co-screenwriter showed me a
bunch of news articles about this batch
yeah exactly crisper gosh and and we
wrote the last two films together
tangerine and starlet and which I would
love for you guys to see if you haven't
seen starlet
it's like Harold and Maude meets Boogie
Nights that's awesome yeah awesome yeah
okay okay okay I have blu-rays for you
guy way after Harold and Maude beach
buggy night all right cool no one
doesn't want to see Ruth Gordon get
[ __ ] getting back to this we he showed
me a bunch of news articles about the
fact that there were families with
children living in these budget motels
right outside the place we consider the
happiest place on earth three kids so
that juxtaposition in that irony we
thought was just so special and we
wanted to focus on that and shine a
light on it but we also wanted to make
this film entertaining so and Bunny and
make it like The Little Rascals so that
I've been very inspired by The Little
Rascals my whole life and we wanted to
find like the new Spanky and their whole
gang of friends and then surround him by
crazy adults like this one so I write in
check
how do you find that girl like how do
you that your lead character like how do
you find child actors that can pull this
off because there's like you know as
much as there's a little rascals element
you know there's a highly emotional
story component you you can't see the
whole film because like she is freaking
amazing her healing Brooklyn Prince with
two N's
she already has a Hollywood name she was
a local hire she lived in Orlando we
found her through the local agency and
she's like on the level of like Mickey
Rooney or like Shirley Temple Jodie
Foster the Fanning's she she knew what
she was doing I didn't have to
manipulate it with editing
named Brooklyn right yeah hello yeah
she's right she does the tears when we
need it she's funny she's witty she was
able to like improvise with Willem and
and Sandy and just just really like a
star I know she's gonna be a kids don't
have that whole thing of embarrassment
so it's like if you ask someone who if a
kid has some kind of an ability to act
and you ask them to do something they're
not embarrassed Leo I'm gonna look bad
they just do it they don't give a [ __ ]
plus you had to hire extroverts you have
to like you don't want a few shy kids it
also was incredible to me and also we
were like this is a rated R film you
know I think we all have the same sense
yes I really am because I mean I'm
looking forward to going back to the New
York Film Festival at Lincoln Center and
I'm in New York I'm just to go in on the
Lincoln Center [ __ ] on the inside you
know I mean you covered up Sandy's nips
artfully no you know what that wasn't
scripted that way we wanted a full
topless scene I just happened to be with
the angles in her arms it was like it
became my light a mire where she didn't
tell us and suddenly like we those are
nipples nipples no but but they're good
to light on fire cuz I stay can you
stick the matches right in no did you
see that trick no amazing when she likes
her breasts on fire I'm sure she matches
she shoves him in her inverted yeah
their self that movie we did it so right
okay so yeah it's been done it's been
done right indeed still new yeah you
know new titties right sure are the
things they want you to do movies about
because your subject matter is always
really really original other things they
want you to do a movie about yeah it's
just kind of in cover too many times
sort of I've been like trying to make a
name for myself an independent film for
so long like I've been paying rent with
these tiny little Indies but they
haven't broken until tangerine and now
that I'm actually getting like studio
attention and stuff like that I'm just
like [ __ ] you I'm gonna continue into it
but like like tangerine obviously gets
enough buzz that that's I'm assuming
what enabled you to get the money to do
this movie the right way right
so this movies getting even more buzz in
tangerine I find like they're looking
see really yeah they're really and it's
not sort of like buzz like oh this is
the iPhone movie it's like see like that
yeah they always talk about because my
wife works in film and like every single
movie is like well we're looking for
like a little miss sunshine like right
it's all the indie movie that costs no
money that ends up making it you know
and I'm getting Awards yeah but like you
know they're talking about this movie
like it's gonna get mainstream its yeah
atome award a 24 living it out right
moonlight room a bunch of other like
really highbrow films that broke out
from the art crowd scene to the
mainstream and and so I think they look
for films that have that crossover
potential and do you have an idea of
like let's say this this movie does well
and I was like you don't want to you
don't want to share it let's say for
than 600 million yeah let's say does
well enough right that you can get
you're only in one shot make the next
one right so yeah things one at a time
isn't it do you have an idea of like
what is I'm gonna have all this
attention on me I'm gonna be in a
positive place like what's the movie
that I want to make now you know I I
don't know I'm still trying to figure it
out it's like I'm really influenced by
70 cinema you know like French
Connection and women to lure severs yeah
yeah exactly
and maybe do one of those
maybe do one of those you know 70 try
try Homer no contemporary but like yeah
that's diet but don't miss I miss a lot
of the things we only have a couple of
minutes left to but things would breathe
easier than a lot of films now like you
see like conversations and 70s films
that you would never leave that
intangible - yes yeah yes a lot of New
York cinema like frigging like taking a
Pelham one two three even the later
stuff like classy tenant you know it's
my favorite you know sandy I don't know
if you've talked about if you guys
talked about it but you could do a
spin-off of the Florida project just
around sandy a character would you want
to do that sandy of course got her to
Florida banjo Vishu a baker we did have
a back story for this character like how
she was a tourist that just showed up
and never left
yeah and moved in and never left yeah
yeah she's one of the residents by the
way at this hotel oh yeah her name is
Gloria yeah and she a [ __ ]
warrior
she was really you know a [ __ ] just
like when you do on the show man and now
he's in a movie it's awesome she was
begging us to sing that song
how did you not let that go let it go
but there are a lot of songs in the
movie right no celebration is what we
opening them and from that point on
we're just like the music is great that
you used it's just one song
well I guess they listen to hip-hop from
there like there there there I yes there
what stuff really
stop yelling the movie know the ending
stop saying music sandy oh there is a
little bit of music there's a lot of
music in you not a lot one of the things
that makes this movie good is there is
not a sound for Sam we have one minute
at the end is music right yeah there's
music at the end